[Musica]
rosso rosa mi hai rubato il cappello a
fiore che cosa mi è sempre stato isolato
questo è il mio nuovo cappello foglia
visto che tu ma in quanti siamo questa
volta celeste e c'erano anche giallo e
lì sarà l'impostore questa volta giallo
provate a indovinare chi è l'impostore
prima della fine del video ma mi
raccomando l'unica regola è nessuno
spoiler nei commenti
non scrivete nei commenti chi è
l'impostore vi avevo detto che se lo
scorso video mulas nella vita reale due
avesse raggiunto i 20 mila mi piace
abbiamo fatto una terza parte del bene
lo scorso giugno i 30mila vi piace anche
questo video raggiunge i 30 mila mi
piace si sarà una quarta parte e magari
sarà interattiva in cui dovrete decidere
voi cosa fare e gli air e poi le varie
caselline quindi volli chat e ora non
c'è tempo da perdere iniziamo a fare le
nostre tasse
okay bene ora che il rosso se n'è andato
sia mussolini due io sospetto di giallo
voi di chi sospettate ho intenzione di
seguire il giallo per un po e vedere
cosa vediamo se riusciamo a trovarlo
spero di sì
pure task andiamo
sembra che qualcuno abbia sabotato
questi figli magari l'impostore è stato
proprio in questa stanza allora devo
ricordarmelo allora come si faceva
questa task blu e rosa
no giallo giorno con giallo si no questo
è blu non è giallo ecco perché allora
blu lo collego con blu poco blu non con
giallo
ecco perché ho preso la scossa grazie
per l'inglese è venuto ad aiutarmi
come dice celeste con celeste si sembra
funzionare
bravo tornino è completata da tasca per
me grazie avete visto il giallo da
qualche parte forse eguale il reattore
andiamo
[Musica]
è un giallo una sorpresa per te ebbene
sì sono io l'impostore e non mi resta
che liminare rossoceleste anzi eliminerò
solo rosso così rimane solo celeste e
vincerò la challenge
anzi andiamo subito a cercare grosso
secondo voi dovrei riportare il corpo
sarei troppo sospetto è meglio lasciar
perdere
entro in un vento è fatto alla ricerca
di rosso
[Musica]
ciao
[Applauso]
ok se nessuno ci può stare ma c'è
nessuno vediamo se ci porti a far sì che
mi piace tanto eppure ok fatto ma ci
sono ancora vogliono sbaglio come è
possibile che ci sono ancora tutte le
foglie che strano e quali sono sicuro di
averla appena passata è stata sta troppo
strano questa cosa va bene vorrà dire
che la rifarò ok questa volta è stata
fatta per la terra
certe riportato il colpo di giallo stato
eliminato e chi è stato forse è stato
celeste perché è stato celeste e trovare
giallo sei stato tu cenette sì è vero
che è stato celeste a riportare giallo
però tutto richiesta incolpando celeste
perché anche il sospetto secondo me
celeste sospetto no secondo me tu sei
sospetta come io allora fai tu sospetto
sono stato io gli stavo facendo data
spazi e poi liga stavi facendo delle
foglie da o ripulendo un sistema di
areazione da tutte le foglie non ci
credo tanto preferiamo non dovuta anche
di fare perché non stava funzionando
bene forse avevo sbagliato a far la
prima volta effettivamente e va bene ti
credo allora io godo cerette e io voto
rosa
no non è stato eliminato nessuno tu hai
votato celeste io ho votato te e celeste
a scappato
uffa l'impostore quindi sbrighiamoci
facciamo le tasche dai sbrigati vai a
fare le tasche io cerco delle task qua
tu sei un po sospetta perché per chi
stai parlando
ma quello che dico sempre si sospetta
secondo me celeste celeste chi è
sospetto per te dovesse vincere ste si
bye bye bye pure rivali dunque sono
aspetta due l'ho scampata ragazzi
stavano per scoprirmi ma per fortuna non
mi hanno scoperto per fortuna celesta
non ha visto che sono stata io eliminare
giallo ora devo continuare con il mio
piano di eliminare rosso ora entra in
una botola un avente e andiamo subito ad
eliminarmi secondo voi ce la farò a
vincere questa partita da impostore
andiamo
ei sei venuto anche tu a fare le tasche
sì sì devo fare è inquadrata magari
hanno fatto prima io e devo controllare
che l'hai fatta bene ok sto facendo la
mia task e lì e questa mi deve venire ad
interrompere che vuoi perché mi stai
sempre incollato cosa stai nascondendo
dietro niente ho visto qualcosa dietro
basta bisogna fare
e vado a riportare rosa chiudiamo le
fate in corso oggi voto serve fuori e
ucciso le porte ora rimaniamo io lotto
motori finito rosso è scappato
spero che non sia il solito può chiamare
l'emergency meeting perché ora sia rosso
che cede sessano che sono l'impostore
non lo trovo più ho un'idea gli
preparerò una trappola
ciao ragazzi sono rosso mi sono nascosto
qui in mezzo ai divani così magari
l'impostore non mi vede che non mi trova
ha chiuso le porte e ha bloccato celeste
in un'altra stanza quindi sono rimasto
bloccato qui in questa stanza con lei
aiuto ho paura che mi prenda meglio se
rimango nascosto qui in mezzo ai divani
ma cos'è quella cosa sul tavolo che può
andare subito a controllare gli scontri
infatti visto credo
[Musica]
[Applauso]